all right Sherlock Sherlock where you
from originally I was born in Detroit
but I've been out here since I was 8
years old tell me about your uh family
growing up you had Mom and Dad uh
actually uh my grandparents my mom and
dad were in the picture but uh my father
was an addict and uh my mom really
wasn't there so I was raised by my
grandparents uh they had a lot of family
out here and my grandparents you know
they wanted to get to be by their
sibling siblings so my Grandmama came
out here and by me being a grandma boy
and my sister being up of my granddaddy
wherever they went we wanted to come to
and we came out here and uh we moved to
89th in Broadway 89th in Broadway and I
had an aunt that lived in Santa Monica
so from school after I got kicked out of
school in La I went back and forth to
Santa Monica to here I end up graduating
from Santa Monica and uh you know
uh out here running the streets
and uh growing up in the gangs you know
I got a uh I got jumped in when I was 11
years old I got jumped in when I was 11
years old
uh doing what we do uh end up going to
juven going this is where it started I
end up going to juvenile hall and I was
such a [__] up to where they wouldn't
let me sleep with the general population
they made me go to ICU in was rooms and
at that time they didn't call them uh
transgenders you know they were called
drag queens and I seen one and I didn't
know Le I didn't one and0 and we started
talking and writing letters and stuff
and you know I call her my first little
girlfriend I was like 14 at the time you
know what I mean her name was Nancy
redhead Nancy they call her D now I did
get a chance to see her again so I grew
up back and forth uh it was difficult
cuz I'm a gang member so uh you know I
heard the jokes you know if you flip you
flop you reach around this and that and
this and that but once I once they
realized that I was going to fight you
know laid off on the jokes you know what
I mean and actually this is what I do
I've been messing with these girls I
call them girls that's what they are to
me uh like you say your last uh guy in
with Thailand you know uh I wouldn't
mind marrying one too you know if I
could just calm down and settle down cuz
that's what I I do you know what I mean
uh I have three kids four grandchildren
so I'm not confused about my sexuality
you know this is what I like this is
what I've always liked uh I put it out
there
I have tattoos like I said to should
prove it you know what I mean uh I have
six uh dead girls over here uh I'm
left-handed so I put the ones that I've
been with on my left hand this side and
my friends you know just as I mean like
Papa's a homie so if I known papa for 20
years and I've known these girls for 20
25 years they're home girls too so why
don't they deserve to get some type of
recognition so I have them on my right
side you know
uh I've Loved I've lost I've I've
learned a lot dealing with them you know
what I mean and I like it because people
say uh a real man you know doesn't do I
guess what I do well if that's been a
real man then I'm glad to be a fake man
cuz I like what I like you know and I
enjoy it uh there was a time when I
remember I took a girl home for
Thanksgiving
1996 Thanksgiving dinner meal family and
I was still kind of shy at that time she
sit over there most of the time and I
you know sit over here most of the time
and now I look back on it you know I was
young I was still worried about what
people was say even though my dad and my
mom they were they didn't care you know
I was still kind of worried but over the
years of dealing with them and and being
a part of them I can remember the first
time I hit the boulevard somebody said
what's your
tea who my tea what's that they was like
what's your tea you know what's up you
know my tea cuz I'm life from West Side
over I ain't got no [__] tee
what you mean but you know I realized
that it was their way of saying you know
what's up you know and so I've adapted
you know to the lingo Tino shade or
whatever you know I periodically say it
and uh you know people think it's funny
like they go with that [__] but it's
a part of me you know I don't try to
deny it uh today I'm to the point to
where you know I walk down the street
with that's what I look for you know I
look at women and I admire them yeah wow
Lord Mercy Jesus Christ she's gorgeous
only if you know she had a kickstand you
know what I mean that that would be
perfect you know because I mean I'm into
everything about him uh at one point no
I mean I was young I would try to hide
and know being a homeboy [__] gets out
you know I saw you over here what were
you doing over here why were you on this
part of the jail Sherlock I heard this I
heard that okay well if you heard it it
was true why is you worried about my
dick anyway you know and uh they don't
[__] with me anymore you like okay they
go shlock that's the but uh you know I
mean I've been stabbed six
times
uh I've
been okay seven times I've been stabbed
seven times dealing with them uh I've
been in altercations on the Boulevard
Santa Monica Boulevard coming from clubs
and we're just walking down the street
and people gay bashing you know throwing
eggs getting out you know what I'm
saying wanting to beat up you know gay
bash and yeah I mean I'm the way I see
it is if if if if if she's a [__] then
then what the hell am
I here's a [__] that'll fight so you
know you know there been times I was
like girl this n don't want to fight
don't man want to fight a girl let let
me use your pumps let me let me let me
put that gild which is a wig let me put
this gild on and maybe this thing will
fight you know what I'm saying he don't
want to fight a man he want to fight a
girl so you know I've done that and uh
I've clowned I mean it's just so it's
fine is do you prefer trans women to
regular women yes I do you do I don't go
back and forth I was just telling uh my
buddy earlier today I said not too long
ago I was in a a tent and uh I was in
there getting high and this woman walked
in I said excuse me I said I can't allow
you to come in you know such and such is
not here she said he said of school you
know I can come in and smoke I'm like
okay cool after a few Puffs I thought I
said excuse me just a minute I stepped
out I said he man a transgender he said
no man that's said girl a girl oh girl
I'm wasting my dog man what the [__] you
do I [__] with up girls like that you
know he said so like you for real man I
don't go back and forth man I ain't got
time to be lying and explaining and none
of that type of [__] he was like man you
crazy but you used to be straight yeah
yeah like I said I have three children
you know three children uh I can
remember I got a phone call one day
about s was with me and I said Cory I
said man I'm not going to take you I'm
I'm have to drop you off he said why I
said man I'm going to go out meet some
girls and stuff he said I like
girls I said Cory these ain't the kind
of girls that go to your school man I
said uh I said you know what I meant to
Cory he said Oh Daddy man I a none of
that old gay [__] I said look here you
don't have to respect nobody just don't
disrespect them I said you go in hey how
you doing I'm introducing my son and you
know she be cool so we get upstairs oh
first he said do they smoke Weg I said
oh good they got you already
so uh we go upstairs and I introduce him
as my son and one of my one of my
friends said oh my God look at him I
can't wait till he get 18 and I'm
thinking
18 okay [__] you got the same doctor I
got what the hell you mean you can't
wait till he get 18 this is my son you
know so uh I was always told not to put
nobody covers or tell nobody's you know
business so uh I just told him uh I said
Cory look at man uh you know your
father's condition I said you make sure
you wear condoms in all that you do you
know what I mean he said oh Dad I a't
with that I don't know what you with
Cory I didn't us should be with a lot of
[__] I said but that's yours that's your
responsibility I said people will not
tell you I said because uh no one wants
to be rejected I said but I'm telling
you make sure you strap on he said oh
Dad I got you I got you I got you I'm
like okay [__] you got me all right I
done told you you know uh my dad you
know he had so he used to hang out on
the boulevard with me uh one night me
and my mom and dad I said come on let's
go hang out let's go out they was like
all right go on let's go we went to the
study it was a uh gay club on Thursday
nights you know uh girls would uh lip
syn you know do the songs and stuff like
that and I would I would be down here on
F and Crocker and instead of giving
people money I would go up there and I
would tip that would be my way of
contributing so I took my mom and dad up
there me and my dad in the back talking
you know with the girls trying
and I'm like where's my mom at so I go
up in there to see my mom and she like
she me Me Halfway she said you got some
ones I said some ones
said I gave her a c she said no no
that's not enough and she turned around
and I seen the stripper I said oh my so
I go to the bar I get the change you
know what I'm saying and my mama's
stripper and whatever you know okay do
what you do you know I'm going in the
back with my dad you know so uh my I got
stabbed six times on Santa Monica
Highland Santa mon Canta monican hiding
is where it really really had all
started for me I was uh a gr gr used to
send us out to work and they sent me to
Griffith Park so on my way from Griffith
Park on Western of Santa Monica I saw uh
apartment building for you know
apartment for rent I'm like okay cool we
can afford this if something happens to
me she with her County check she can
still afford to pay the rent and it was
Santa Monica in Wilton it's called the
Harvey apartments and uh I was really I
was naive I walk down the street and
people would blow horns and hey hey and
I'm thinking okay you know I'm a Hoover
but don't nobody over here know me I
didn't know that this was a blade uh uh
you know male prostitution whatever and
uh one day I went to the donut
time and uh I seen a bunch of girls oh
my God they had s that all short scourt
and everything I died and went to heaven
but then when I looked at one I looked
all the way down
oh God that's a me oh [__] I got kind of
spook because once I realized one I saw
it in all of them I said oh [__] I know
what I wanted but I didn't know what
they wanted they were bigger than me you
know I mean this you know this back in
the day right and they're like oh look
at the T what's the T Mama trade they're
like trade I'm like trade I ain't got
nothing to trade with I Ain no dope [__]
am I going to trade you know what I'm
saying but that was a turn for a
straight guy who met around uh this was
93 this was 93 and uh so I've been uh
but once I saw that I never left I
started hanging out there selling drugs
there and uh I remember my first little
girl out there I had uh seen her one day
her name was Latrice and uh she said uh
we used to call her leis back then and I
remember I remember saying you know
what's up well what's up for the night
she was like I'm working right now
so I'm like at that time when they were
working I just fell back or whatever
they were working you know I said so
when I'm going to see you again she said
you saw me this time didn't you I'm like
okay so I finished doing what I was
doing and later on the night I looked
she was standing right there with
something else on a whole different
outfit and she said you ready I said
yeah yeah I'm ready so we hopped in the
taxi and went to my place when we got to
my place I pull out my money she said
what are you doing I said what she said
you a trick or what I said a trick I
said no I'm just paying for the taxi she
said [__] as long as you on this
Boulevard you don't pay for a goddamn
thing she said you trade she said
whatever we need I got it and if we
don't have enough I'm GNA go out and get
some
more oh [__] okay all right now if I
tell some girls some [__] like that
today you know they going to be chasing
me off the block because times have
changed you know what I mean times have
changed but that's the era I come up
under uh Mark all I had to do was stay
out of the next girl's face but I was
young uh uh I'm living in a house with
five five of them and I'm trying to just
be with one and when they all go out at
night somebody leave with purse and
they'll come back or the door will knock
and I'll open it I didn't know now what
I know then now if she leaves I'm not
open in that door you know what I mean
if you left something she going have to
call me and tell me cuz I I mean I I
know the game you know what I mean uh
but I had to learn a lot man uh I had to
learn a lot uh there's so many women
that when I say women that's what I mean
trans women there's so many women and
girls that I've had a chance to meet you
know uh I really love these girls you
know it's uh I do you know and sometimes
I come around here I have money or
whatever I'll just go just to hang out
with them or whatever look at the food
here go take my card you know go get you
something to eat fill the ice box up or
go do a [__] you know I've been KN you
for 20 years that's the least I could do
you know what I mean and uh you know
today I came down to you know get my
hair braided I said some I'm going see
someone and you know they going to braid
myir my homeboy you know um my children
know uh I
uh I've always I've always thought I
couldn't be touched you know what I mean
I've always thought I couldn't be
touched and uh she's no longer with us
you know what I mean but uh I fell in
love with one and every time I come home
before I come home from prison I get a
testt I call up my my driver's license
you know I take a test and uh this
particular time driver's license had
expired you know what I mean I was found
reactive you know which is positive and
uh I didn't know how to my wife and kids
they had put up with so much infidelity
lying [__] jail Street stuff me
smoking PCP tattooed all over my body I
didn't really know how to tell them I
said damn okay I've done enough so I
kind of I I shifted away and I let the
you know I let them go uh do I regret it
yes because I'm not closest with my
children as I should be but I thought I
did the right thing you know I had to
make a choice and uh I didn't choose the
streets or what looks like it but I was
young I didn't know how to you know I
didn't know how to put it out there you
know the stigma and things like that so
uh I just floated around for a while for
a while and then I uh I took some
courses and once I became a peer
educator uh specialized in HIV awareness
havec uh human papalon virus HPV I
understood some things I understood that
it could be any of us and now I make a
joke if I was uh was Charlie Shen or
MADD Johnson you wouldn't kick me out of
bed don't kick me out of bed you know
what I mean uh I can
remember girls would always you take a
shower face her the other way you know
not one you know me to see everything
and stuff and there was this one girl oh
my God she was so beautiful and uh she
was up front she said well sure like I'm
a guns singer which means she uses her
tool and I'm like okay baby it's okay
you just point your pistol somewhere
else you know what I mean it's no te say
she said but said like why you got to be
so tough everybody's doing it no [__]
everyone you know is doing it okay not
too much she end up being my first and
and uh I love her to this day you know
what I mean and and I'm having these
feelings for her I'm like what the [__]
am I feeling like this for her I'm like
see this is why you don't dib and dab
because you might like [__] you know
what I mean but
uh and I you know I end up I end up
liking it you know I end up liking what
I do you know and uh I tell you know
Papa all the time I said that man if
they're not fully functional man you
know I have no use for you know you
prefer them to have a little mail
equipment yeah exactly what is it about
a transom that you prefer over a a
regular woman I just like the whole get
down you know I mean I think it's a
struggle you know it's very very
difficult to get up and dress up it's
very very difficult to to do this all
day every day and be consistent with it
you know what I mean to have the heart
you know to walk down the street in
heels and and Scar
and and still let alone what people
might think you know you you you you got
got to have boss to do stuff like that
you know what I mean and
uh I I I mean I to me they're real you
know people say well the first thing
they did is lie and tell me that you
know the name was kha well I do know
this once feelings are involved it
wouldn't matter if it was Kea Kim Tom
Hanks whoever you know uh I love I love
that about him I love the way that they
I love the way that they care for
me you know I love the way that they
care for me you know
uh uh well first of all they can't have
any kids and I don't want any more kids
so you know we have that in common do
you think you had this inclination
before you uh had had children with your
was it a wife oh yes I did because uh um
even before my even before I had
children uh I was on 82nd in figuro one
day and I pulled up on this girl and she
didn't want to have she was like uh I'm
cool I'm cool what do you mean she said
look I don't want a problem I don't want
a problems she said I said what do you
mean she said look I'm a queen I don't
want no problems I said a queen I said
well baby I'm a king I said baby we can
get together and make some Jacks you
know I've always been foolish you know
cards king queen Jacks I said maybe we
can get together and make some Jacks she
said you don't understand she said I'm a
drag I'm a man I said she's a p I said
what and I was with one of the homies
I'm like all right go get me out of here
you know took me to the hood really what
he did was drop me off I hop back in my
[__] and I went looking I was droing up
and down F looking for this and I seen
her maybe week later the homies got a
call that one of our home girls is
getting into with another girl and when
we all got to the motel I knew that that
was a transgender I said L I said good
that's a transgender she got squabbled
look he said what I said no no no no no
I said please please I said don't tell
who I won't mention his name I said but
don't tell him I said cuz he'll killer
don't don't tell him I said just let her
go just let her go I said I'll deal with
her later just let her go I said yeah I
got this i got this don't worry about it
I deal with this later I know I know it
I know so after she left they didn't try
to follow her whatever seen her uh in
jail and we were talking and she said
you remember me I got in to with some of
your homies one night and I did this and
I did that I said no baby that's not the
way H remember I said but I know it's
you I said cuz you still got them black
panties on with that ass like that and
when your legs went up she was like boy
you too much you know so we end up uh we
hooking up we end up hooking up matter
of fact her name is the first name uh
that I have one my
left side right here Jenna Jackson I
have uh they are thece uh Jenna Jackson
the Chanel Lani
champagne London and Foxy these are all
names I have one ins side uh
theisha
laquisa
muffin Laquisha
muffin uh Laquisha
muffin
Amber Jodie White
Buffalo fun names and one more I would
have to look they're all on you know
this side because they were just friends
you know we didn't have sex but they
were still my you know they were my
girls there different blades you go to
to find these girls all of these girls
I've met in
Hollywood or these ladies I met is that
Santa Monica Boulevard yes Santa Monica
Boulevard uh it's not the same anymore
the donut time is now I think Trey host
tacos that sit on the corner of s of
monigan high yeah uh the Del Taco isn't
there uh yeah the whole Boulevard has
changed but that's why you're down here
on Skid Row as well yes but this is a
whole different oh they got some
beautiful women down here on Skid Row
but I'm going tell you skid
bro the back streets that's what I mean
yeah when you get the 15 in palan whole
another world 3:00 in the morning they
standing out there with Batman costumes
on oh my God it's like beautiful and
sometimes I I go back there just to look
you know what I'm saying he said wow you
know I mean they're they're gorgeous and
they're proud you know they're doing
their thing they're not bothering no and
and they're cool they with the [__]
they with all of that you know I can
remember a time in prison so when I went
to prison I saw one and I said what's up
baby and she said nothing and I knew
back then it was race you know we
couldn't be caught she couldn't say
nothing to me if she wanted to you know
uh it used to be like that but it's not
like that anymore we had a place uh off
of Detroit in Santa Monica called The
Mining Company the Yukon restaurant full
of Hispanic girls and the restaurant was
open 24 hours that's probably why I've
been stabbed up but I would take the
wife there you know to dinner and the
kids and I would said she I got to go to
the
bathroom while I was in the bathroom
with the girls I mean that that was just
me you know I mean I wasn't I wasn't fit
to be married I wasn't fit to be honest
or anything like that you know I was
really like a a child in a candy store
the candy mention your father earlier
was he into this as well no my father
wasn't you know my father would uh come
with me uh cuz he was getting dope at
the time but he was uh you know he was
not into any of it you know what I mean
uh I've had a matter of fact I had a
girl uh she was following me around so I
took her home I said okay well let me
get us a try go clean up and this and
that and uh while I introduced her to my
dad she went upstairs and uh like 15
minutes later my dad said monkey he said
man get this [__] out my house I'm like
what I said what do you mean he said get
this [__] I said that he said matter of
fact you and this [__] get out my house
so I go upstairs and she's naked and she
has a tie around her arm trying to tie
to shoot up and she said I asked him if
he knew how to hit I said [__] why
would you ask my daddy some [__] like
that she said well I thought if if you
since you messed around and you was cool
I thought your dad [__] that's what you
give a thought when you should have been
thinking you know what I mean so uh but
me and my dad we got by past that we got
over that like I say uh I don't have my
phone with me but I have pictures of my
mom took out on the boulevard with me
and the girls uh how many it was fun
back then you know what I mean I mean uh
since then you know uh we're in the
neighborhood I remember was in the hood
one day we were shooting dice and the
homie said hey lock girls came looking
for you and one of the homies said [__]
girls came looking for Sherlock ain't no
telling what it is you better check with
Adam apple all type of it so I've been a
joke you know what I mean uh then
sometime a matter of fact I was down
here on F and Crocker and I asked uh a
girl to go get me some cigarettes I said
I'll go she said I'll go for you
Sherlock and uh when she came back I was
hanging out with the homies and the home
girls and she got out the car and walked
right up she said here you go Daddy I
said thanks babe I gave her a hug I said
I'll see you later they was like how
that's a man they was like what the [__]
the girls was like that's a man and I
heard some dude say that man got my ass
all you [__] out here they was like
Go sir like you know do your thing so uh
you know stuff like that I've taken them
to our we had a strip club in the hood
right off Hoover and uh between Figo
over in uh Florence we go up in there
and you know they car theirself like
ladies where's the lady's room you know
they tip I mean it's just and they be
like shlock are you for real shlock
what's that you know my my mama said boy
look at that app my mama said I want
some of what she taking you know cuz she
saw the body and stuff you know so uh I
mean I've had fun over the years you
know uh there's nothing I wouldn't do
for him you know this is a new different
a different day in age and some of them
are new and stuff and um I I do
understand things but it's becoming more
accepted
and that's the thing it's socially
acceptable now you know LGBT and I get
at people sometime I'll be like where
was y'all at when it was hard to be gay
when [__] was chasing us off
the street and throwing [__] at us and
it's me and two girls fighting and I'm
trying to tell them to go so I cuz I
can't do my [__] and watch her too baby
just go I'll catch up to you where were
all these people at now you know what I
mean now I have a uh Al of lifestyle or
or this and that it was difficult back
then can you imagine me and a bunch of
penitentiary dudes and everybody's
handcuffed to each other and I'm
handcuffed to somebody that's taller
than me with a ponytail and a weave and
smacking some bubblegum you know doing
this but I endured that you know what I
mean and uh I'm proud of it you know I
wouldn't change it for anything in the
world uh a lot of guys are on the down
low with this yeah to me there's nothing
about I tell them at all there's nothing
about me being down though you know I
tell it's refreshing to to meet a man
who freely admits it I tell dudes I said
no no no I'm in the transgender women
well it it's all the same if you been in
over face now here's the thing we're not
even going to have that much
communication where you can think about
being bend over because I'm not even
going to I'm not going to get high with
you I'm not going to elaborate on you
you know what I mean I don't I say look
I'm gay uh you can call me Tre this and
that I'm not going to explain my
sexuality to to them you know uh I'm gay
but I have a what do you call it I have
a preference you know we all eat meat
some people don't like fish we have a
preference you know and uh I tend to
flock to areas where they're at you know
and sure a lot of them may not know me
and be like them who is this guy why
he's all around but if you talk to one
or they get to know me or know someone
okay that's who that is oh I what
happened to him it's not what happened
happened to him you know I grew up you
know uh I got gr you know I've had a
stroke you know I'm say sometimes I get
high and and I I SP myself so I can you
know I see why people don't uh approach
but you know the love is always there
you know what I mean uh I'll give them
my last uh I always do uh as a matter of
fact one here uh dropped off here one
time and waited and when we left you
know she had a little money and stuff
and she was talking and everything was
falling out of her pocket and stuff and
the guy said uh how well do I do you
know her I said I know her well enough
for you to not mess with her [__] you
know what I mean and once I got away
from him I said here sweetheart here's
your money she said I dropped it I said
but sweetheart I just picked it up and
took it out your PR before the dud that
you was with did it I said here's all
your money it's all there she said oh my
God sir I thank you thank you thank you
I'm like okay cool she said do you know
what my dope is I wasn't looking for a
dope I was trying to make sure you had
your money and she said well dang if if
the dope is I said sweetheart really I
said I've been had your money all this
time and you talking about some drugs
she said I love you sir lot and you know
I told her friend they said sir like she
wouldn't have did that for you well
here's the thing I don't love people I
don't do for people because of how they
feel for me you know I do it because of
how I feel about them you know uh some
of these tattoos I have people say sira
you think they love you like that these
tattoos don't represent how much they
love me about how much I love them you
know so let's not get it twisted you
know what I mean uh and I've just always
been like that Mark uh what would you
say Sherlock is the most important
lesson you've learned in your
life to be
honest to be honest to be honest and the
reason I say that is I'm 52 now my
closest friends are the ones that I have
not slept with just being honest because
someone's going to tell it and they may
tell it wrong so if you tell it the
right way at least you know you told it
the right way and I have a saying that
goes in order to get to the second date
you have to do what you have to do good
on the first dat you know what I mean so
uh I'm still shy but I mean I'm out
there everyone knows but I don't
approach because just because I'm
feeling some way doesn't mean everyone
else is feeling some way you know if I
get higher sexually promiscuous that
doesn't mean she is so for me to
approach in that type of way I might
mess up a friend so I rather just sit
back and just do me and just see how it
fans out you know what I mean just to be
honest man because someone's going to
tell it and uh What's Done in the Dark
is going to come to light it may not
come to light the right way so why not
tell it at least that way you know what
to get you know you feel comfortable you
know what I mean you'll feel
comfortable the only regrets I have in
life are missed
opportunities missed
opportunities all right missed opportun
shck thank you so much for sharing your
story thank you it's been a pleasure
very interesting that's the truth you
know uh they say I said your books your
Life's a open book welley you know what
I mean it is what it is you know and
with that being said I'm going to go
find some to hang out with right
now have
fun